thanks everyone for coming here today
this should be a cool session we've been
talking a lot about personal data and
health data but what what Nikolas
research is is the way that networks of
people affect each other's health now if
you you originally got interested the
question of of how social behaviors sort
of flow contagiously from one person
another how did that happen where did
that interest come from well it's the
story I've told before but I came up as
a hospice doctor so I'm in addition to
being a social scientist I'm a physician
and I take care of people who are dying
or I did until a few years ago and in
the 1990s I was at the University of
Chicago and I was paying house calls to
people who were dying and often they
were being cared for by other
individuals and in my lab at the time I
was studying the widower effect which is
one of the oldest documented cases of
interpersonal health effects so if I die
my wife's risk of death goes up right
and and sort of one day I became aware
of the fact that actually the widowhood
effect which is my death causing my
wife's death or vice versa is a special
case of a broader phenomenon that
actually it's not limited to a dyadic
affects one person upon another nor even
limited to death actually all kinds of
phenomena can spread and they spread
well beyond just pairs of individuals
and that led to a series of interests
and investigations and ultimately in
2001 I moved to Harvard University and
then met James Fowler my long-term
collaborator and then we started a whole
bunch of project you were trying to
figure out how to how to measure whether
behaviors can spread really widely yeah
in a population and so you you wound up
finding the framing and heart study
right and so tell me a little bit about
what they had done and how you're able
to use that to find well what we wanted
what we were interested in doing is we
were interested in studying how some
counterintuitive phenomena so most
people are familiar with the fact that
you know fashions can spread right or
germ
can spread but we were interested in a
diverse set of other sorts of phenomena
sort of various human behaviors like
weight gain for example or exercise
behavior or emotions for instance most
people are familiar with the idea that
there can be emotional contagion for
example I gave a talk in New York City a
few years ago where I said you know how
when you're on the subway and and you're
sitting in the subway car and the person
across from the car smiled at you and
you just instinctively smile back and
they said we don't do that in New York
City and I said well everywhere else in
the world that's normal human behavior
so so people are familiar with the
notion of emotional contagion right but
what we were James and I were interested
in doing is we're studying a diverse set
of other phenomena that were
counterintuitive and perhaps more
interestingly in understanding how they
could spread beyond dyads we're not just
from person to person but from person to
person to person and person to person to
person to person and in these
complicated networks which have this
this lightning type branching pattern
which is mathematically very complex so
we needed some data to do this and the
data we needed didn't exist in at the
time we had these ideas and through a
very serendipitous sequence of events we
happened upon some paper records at the
Framingham Heart Study a very famous
epidemiological study that's been going
on since 1948 and we were able to
computerize those records and create the
data that we needed and so you see this
network of people it's about 50 years
right yeah well we studied 32 years of
the data was back 48 you had about 5000
people opening thousand overall 15 I was
over all right and and and networked
about 5,000 networked together more we
had worried about 5,000 embedded in a
network of 12,000 all right and so and
so you look at how they change over time
and you see clusters of them getting
obese for example over time and that was
spreading from friend to friend basing
and from and from space and what not
obesity you found spreading what other
types of things happiness yeah we looked
at a diverse set of phenomena I mean
first we started looking at things like
that we're very public health oriented
like weight gain and weight loss looking
behavior or drinking behavior eating
behavior right and then we started using
other datasets as well not just the
Framingham Heart Study there's a very
famous data set known as add health
which is about a hundred thousand high
school or middle school and high school
kids around the country and then we
started doing experiments and we started
collecting our own other data sets and
we broadened the scope of what we looked
at eventually we became interested in
would regard to be very fundamental on
human behaviors like cooperation right
when an ultra ISM you studied yeah
altruism auto racial ultras and does
spread like if I'm ultra stay yes my
wife my children my friends yeah me more
after we did we use some experimental
data we've done a whole set of projects
on that now kind of looking at the pay
it forward phenomena so what's
interesting is not that you know if I'm
kind to you you might reciprocate the
kindness and this is known as direct
reciprocity and that's interesting and
not easy to explain but not too
difficult to explain either but what we
James and I were interested in is not
whether I'm kind to you then you are
kind to me but whether I'm kind to you
and then you're kind to him and then
he's kind to her and it spreads through
the network and why why does that happen
right which begs a whole set of
questions in evolutionary biology and
and frankly in human genetics so that
then led it to another whole set of
projects where we kept digging deeper
and deeper and in a way if you think
about I mean one of the ways that I've
come to look at human social systems is
that we are a kind of human super
organism you know that we human is a
ghulam rate to form something bigger
than ourselves we do this not just with
when we make groups or networks or
nation-states or communities or
neighborhoods and other kinds of
higher-order structures and we resemble
in some ways other creatures that do
this the well-known example is ants but
their other their certain fungi they
make human super organisms and what what
we became interested in in a way for us
was sort of backwards so first we
started studying the physiology of the
human super organism or the function and
then as we were looking at things
spreading within networks we began to
ask questions about why why does that
otherwise is out and and what's the
structure what's the anatomy of the
human super organism and and that then
led to a set of investigations on human
social networks structure not just
function and then the deep origins of
this structure why do we have the
structure that we do and so for the last
five years or so we've been doing a set
of experiments and other investigations
trying to understand why why not only
why do we make networks but why you
networks have the particular sort of
mathematical structure that they do and
so because this stuff recurred over and
over again I mean you found you found
that no matter what you were looking at
you you got an effect about two hops out
and that but then no further basically
okay so that's that's a functional not
prolonged duration one of the things we
have observed is what we've come to call
in a kind of shorthand way the three
degrees of influence rule so that
everyone is familiar with the six
degrees of separation rule with our
observation which which describes
network structure right what we became
interested in was the observation that
across a variety of empirical data sets
and phenomena it seemed that I could
affect you right and you could affect
him and he could affect her and then the
effect kind of tapers off and dissipates
about three hops well on an average of
three hops sometimes it's two sometimes
it's four sometimes it's not at all
right like not everything spreads but
things that do spread seem on average to
spread to about three degrees of
separation there are number of possible
explanations for this this is not magic
I mean one of the most obvious
explanations is simple decay or friction
in the system so like if you drop a rock
on a pond the rock creates waves but the
waves don't stay at the same amplitude
and go all you know to the periphery of
the pond they dissipate rise the water
molecules have friction with each other
so something similar is one of the
explanations for why that happens in
humans so but that but that is a that
three degrees of influence idea is more
an idea about how networks function
yeah and less an observation about how
networks are structured sure okay so so
one of the things that fastened me with
thinking where when I was look at your
work realizing that there's some there's
some very interesting health
implications for this because you know
just as an example when you looked at
smoking you found that you know people
in the crowd probably know so you know
there's been these a lot of the
hard-working people stop smoking and for
several decades at work we're going down
down down until we got to vote about one
in five but twenty percent of the people
are still smoking and that it just worse
in young people yeah yeah that's right
yeah and it sort of stopped there and
there hasn't been as much success in
getting any lower and there was sort of
a mystery as to why is it that we can
get at that lone not lower and remember
when I looked at your research it seemed
to suggest an answer because the smokers
were clustered networks that were not
connected to non-smokers anymore so if
non-smoking is a contagious behavior
they can't catch it from them because
they're not talking to is is that is
that well that's one possible one way of
looking I mean I've been accused
variously of being a bit of a zealot I
guess I am a kind of a nut village so
you know when you're the hammer
everything looks like a nail or so I
always have to resist the temptation
to see everything as a network
phenomenon yeah and of course there can
be many explanations for the same thing
yeah probably a network story but the
way I would describe this is so imagine
you have a wedding banquet and there are
10 tables of 10 people and uh and I tell
you that every minute a bells going to
ring and 10% of the people going to
leave right there in the extremes or at
least two ways this can happen at the
bell rings and one person from each
table goes and then another bell rings
and then one person from each table goes
and so so the size of the number of
people at any given table declines
smoothly from 10 to 9 to 8 to 7 on down
and the total number of people in the
room declines smoothly but an
alternative way that the people could
leave the room is when the bell rings
everyone at one table gets up and leaves
so then until the very end all the
tables have the same number of people
they have 10 people so any table that
has anybody has 10 people at the table
so this is analogous to what can happen
in networks where clusters of
individuals change your behavior at the
same time in one scenario you have kind
of a smooth kind of homogeneously
distributed through the population
decline in a kind of behavior right
where everyone stochastically
has a kind of probability of quitting
smoking right and in the other scenario
you have whole groups of smokers who are
interconnected quit simultaneously all
get up from the same table and leave so
that by the end you may have a couple of
tables 20 percent right where they just
don't get up and go they're all nobody's
drawing a boat together and yeah and
there's no one at the table that's
getting up and going to sort of
stimulate their reflection so there is a
sense in which that can be happening
yeah so so what are that what are the
public policy implications of
understanding health outcomes as being
affected by these networks of people 8
you know if you sort of say okay so we
know this so we can see things like
happiness depression divorce I
understand
spreading socially but what how does
that change the way we think about
keeping people healthy maximizing you
know good health behaviors and
minimizing bad ones so so James and I
call this our so what question so we
spend the first you know 10 years trying
to figure out how networks what is their
function in their structure and in the
last few years we've begun to turn
earnestly to the problem of trying to
figure out what can we do with this
novel right and so why
well better and our first effort in this
regard was to invent a completely new
way of forecasting epidemics and and
take a second to describe this but the
gist of the idea is imagine a network
most people in the audience now have a
kind of visual sense of these networks
if you have never thought of it before
it looks kind of like Christmas tree
lights like when you take them out at
the new season and they're a big mess
and you kind of take the tendrils and
you kind of try to untangle them and you
put these tendrils of lights and there's
a big mess in the middle and network
kind of looks like that and things can
flow across this network and if I told
you that a germ was going to infect one
of the people in this network where the
lights are people and the wires between
them represent relationships you
probably have the intuition that being
in the middle of the network would be
dangerous because you'd be more likely
to get whatever is that spreading and
more likely to get it sooner and so we
took that insight and we said well what
this means is that if we can monitor if
we can identify central people in a
network and monitor them perhaps using
big data technology we the person in the
middle should be more likely to get an
epidemic disease before the average
person in the network so it's not just
like right now when the CDC is trying to
forecast an epidemic it's it's in
Atlanta and it waits for data to come in
from the field doctors and patients do
their thing data gets fed through a pipe
it goes to CDC and three or four weeks
from now they know where the epidemic is
today and then Google Flu Trends came
out a couple years ago where they say
well we can look at people searching
behavior today and we'll know where the
epidemic is today by calibrating the
model but what our idea lets you do is
it tells you where the epidemic will be
tomorrow actually can tell you where the
epidemic will be in two to six weeks in
the case of h1n1 flu because when the
middle people in the network get it
they're like Sentinel nodes they light
up you know my god this person has it
that means the epidemic is coming so
that was one of our first efforts is to
invent a new way to forecast epidemics
and this works not just for germs but
for anything that spreads ideas
behaviors norms this was exotica Dada at
Harvard right you did yeah so we in
proof of concept was in a paper where we
did an h1n1 outbreak in Harvard college
students but we've since done it in a
variety of unpublished papers which will
be coming out soon showing that it works
online and in other ways and this is
this is interesting I'm sorry I'm
interrupting because a lot of what we've
been talking about here this conference
is about the fact that so you're look at
the network like you a thousands and
millions of people
and one of the things that's been
happening here the conference people
talking about individuals and being able
to monitor their own health and and
collect stuff themselves but also send
out signals and it makes me think well
this is really interesting if you marry
the ability of individuals to monitor
what's happening to them with a network
analysis like that can be highly
predictive like if you knew those people
in networks and they were wired up you
could have an unbelievably quick
response that's exactly right
that's right if you if you had for
instance picking up on another macro
trend in our society on citizen science
imagine that thousands of people in New
York wouldn't take too many couple
thousand volunteered to wire themselves
up and report when they had the flu you
could create a completely and if you
knew their network location which you
could get from phone data or email data
you would have a way in which the New
York Public Health Department could know
that an epidemic was striking New York
City weeks before it actually struck
yeah so you can marry a kind of
individual level data and what James and
our colleague small data is the
old-fashioned there's like between like
a single person and sort of big data
which has thousands but I want to before
we run out time I want to pick up one
thing which is so one set of projects
had to do with trying to begin to invent
new ways to forecast epidemics the other
big strand in are so what kind of
question has to do with okay if you can
understand how human networks are
structured and there's like a lot of
interesting evolutionary biology that we
and others have been doing to try to
understand that and sort of some other
studies but if you can also understand
how they function then you can begin to
think about inventing new ways to target
delivery of beneficial
innovations in social systems so we have
a study right now that we've been doing
in Honduras where they're 32 Highland
villages and we are on have mapped the
networks in collaboration with some
others with Derrick Stafford and Alex
Q's we've mapped these networks and then
we have been targeting the delivery of
public health interventions to specific
locations within the network with the
idea of trying to see can we radically
change and accelerate whether certain
villages adopt certain public health
interventions so if you understand how
things flow within networks in principle
it should be possible to turbocharge
public health behaviors and incidentally
not just public health behaviors but all
kinds of other things for example if you
understand doctor networks the structure
of physician networks you should be able
to sort of see how can you tar
get innovation within networks of
physicians to get doctors to adopt
safety practices or to switch to
generics or switch away from generics or
it's a reduced test ordering or whatever
it is that you're trying to change the
behavior of this social system to do an
understanding of network structure
should facilitate right exactly
in fact that that maybe maybe think I
mean I remember when I what was it what
was a great stat in your in your
original obesity study I mean if your if
your friend becomes obese you have a 50
or a 50 separate 57 percent increased
chance we're gonna go B's yes if a
friend of a friend becomes obese you
you're still got a 20% you even two
nodes over yeah but the really spooky
thing also is it can skip nodes too yet
like it like like if I'm friends with
you you're friends with Jay and then I
start smoking James's chance of smoking
goes yet even if you don't start correct
so that's the people people often ask
about that but it's not magic we're not
talking about action at a distance and
the best way to illustrate this point is
to invite you to reflect on something
like the flu so right now your friend's
friend is sick with the flu and has the
sniffles and infects your friend you
don't know your friends friend by the
way there's no back to a path in this
example and your friend's friend infects
your friend your friend's friend gets
the flu is a carrier of the flu but
doesn't events any symptom right then
they spread the germ to you so you have
now directly causally acquired the flu
as a result of your friend's friend
having the flu
via the intermediary of your friend even
though your friend never had any
symptoms of it and similar things can
happen with behaviors for example my
friend can gain weight they gain weight
let's say because they start eating
poorly
this changes my idea about what
acceptable body size is but I don't
change my behavior or gain weight I do
nothing different now my friend over
here he or she quits her exercise
regimen right in the past before I was
exposed to this friend I might have
thought I know I might have thought to
say to my friend you know you're gaining
some weight maybe you should not drop
your exercise regimen or something
horrible like that ah but now that my
friend over here has gained weight I I
don't see weight gain as being
problematic anymore so I say nothing and
the lack of my intervention let's say
facilitates or increases the risk that
this person will gain weight causally as
a result of this person even though it
didn't affect me so things like that
kind of be
like that or explanations like that can
help explain the skipping process given
given the fact that obesity has become a
big issue in the u.s. has anyone ever
come to you and had an idea for a
network-based intervention that could
actually help with obesity since we
understand it yeah it's a difficult one
to tackle I understand but yes so
there's there's a lot of work being done
in a lot of labs around the country by
lots of people that range in everything
from focus interventions if you think
about like Weight Watchers for example
it is a kind of artificially-created
Network right we bring strangers
together you kind of create you create
what is known as high transitivity in
the system so everyone knows everybody
else and then you see the network with
the desirable property which is an
ideology about weight loss and then and
then presumably reinforced I itself
right you can do everything from that
kind of group formation and network
manipulation type of intervention to
broader interventions where you imagine
targeting particular individuals within
systems based on your assessment of how
influential they are to try to get them
to either not gain weight or to lose
weight and Tom Valente and USC and and
lots of people around the country are
are investigating these types of
interventions right I think we're right
at the time now for questions from the
audience so if we get the microphones
set up for that all right we've got a
bunch of questions at the back there hi
so I know dr. Christakis you've worked
with Framingham data and Facebook data
I'm wondering if this is - two questions
I'm wondering if there is what data sets
what kind of novel data sets you might
be working with now and then a second
question what would your dream dataset
be like the one kind of big storehouse
of data that you'd love to get access to
yeah we James and I have worked with
lots of data at Framingham data the
Facebook data the add health data we've
also done work with some telephone data
from a large European country where we
had in partnership with laszlo barabasi
she's lab had access to data regarding
telephone communications through like
40% of the nation we have collected our
own data from from schools like we just
discussed from Harvard students also we
did a project recently where we map the
social networks of the hodza
gathers only about a thousand hodza left
only about 600 of them live in the
traditional way they hunt in and gather
for their food they have no fixed
possessions to speak of no dwellings no
agriculture and we were able to map
their networks and incidentally the
reason we did that is we wanted to test
the claim that social network
architecture is ancient and in fact
Todd's and networks look just like ours
which is in my eye very interesting
finding so we've done lots of data
collection efforts like that so and we
continue to try to find ways to collect
Network data physician networks and so
forth
my fantasy kind of data said some of it
is sort of in the big data vein sort of
Facebook data plus you know linking
Facebook data for example as James just
did in his recent paper that was in
nature with voter records which are
publicly available or linking Facebook
or other similar data email data phone
data to other information about the
person so you don't have such a thin
data set and this can be done either
with due respect everyone's privacy and
anonymity or by getting informed consent
so one of our ideas again picking up on
the citizen science thing is a kind of
notion of creating an infrastructure so
people can donate their data to science
so imagine you created a kind of
platform where people could voluntarily
surrender with rules that they would
agree to some of their privacy it's just
like you can leave your body for
anatomical dissection but now you could
donate your data to science and if you
can get large enough numbers of people
to do that you could actually create a
rather useful set of data but a real
fantasy would be to be able to find a
defined population a set of villages in
India for example where you would
systematically map the network of these
villages and do so repeatedly across it
since I'm interested in networks I mean
you could have other questions but given
the network interest you would spend
time to do that coupled with detailed
information about the individuals to
really understand the micro dynamics of
how innovation and ideas and behavior
spread within social systems with an eye
towards inventing new methods to make
the world a better place okay we have a
question from the internet here can
social network influences counterbalance
into sort of mass marketing like you
know yeah you know jump in in a weird
way you can think of advertising of you
know frito chips as an attempt to
intervene in a network right now and I
would say in fact social network
influences are vastly more powerful so
if you think about
you know the supermodels are just as
thin as they ever were on the cover of
our magazines
that's a mass-market message that we
send all the time and yet willy-nilly
we're all gaining weight and we are much
more influenced by the behavior of our
friends than we are by these abstract
ideologies or if you think about why do
why do guards abuse prisoners the guards
know that we have a commitment to
respect for human rights and civil
rights in our society and we have all
these abstract ideologies but when the
nearby guards start abusing prisoners
and that's a overwhelms any kind of
mass-market kind of message that someone
will get so I think that the direct
personal messages of you or you may read
a consumer reports or some other kind of
review perhaps and wired of a product
but if your friend who is tech savvy
recommends or fails to recommend the
product that's much more powerful than
an advertising campaign or anything else
so we are definitely influenced by mass
marketing no doubt about it but these
social influences are in my judgment
much more powerful however it's
extremely important to distinguish
online interactions from real
interactions so the way I would think
about this is you know when the
telephone was invented it didn't mean
that any old Schmo that called you with
a phone you would because they used the
phone you would do what they said the
phone rings oh my god it's from the
phone someone is telling me I should do
something oh okay you're using the phone
I'm going to do it however if your
friend use this technology to call you
and said you should do something then
you would do it so what matters is not
the medium its who the person that's
sending you the signal is and it's the
same on Facebook just because you can be
connected to a thousand people doesn't
mean that if any old one of your
Facebook friends evinces a certain
property you're going to just
willy-nilly copy them but if one of your
real Facebook friends among all those
weak online interactions does something
then that medium can accelerate your
acquisition of the information in
affected we and have done a number of
products and watts and others have done
a number of projects exploring these
ideas terrific we've got a few minutes
left to someone have a very quick
question that can be answered in like 30
seconds all right let's go for let's try
so this is about the practical side of
it so in DC we have all these problems
in health care both if you have the
dream ability to say which one I wanted
to do to change what problem would you
go after and is
DC interested enough to help you do that
you got 30 seconds next go alright uh I
guess I'm going to give a very parochial
answer which is I would I would broaden
the problem and say that I'm really
interested in the science of behavior
change you know how do we get people
because I think that is a very
fundamental and lies at the core of so
many other health problems so I'm not
going to give you a specific disease or
a specific problem but instead I'm going
to give you a set of topics and and as
you can imagine there's no single thing
that you can do to magically change
human behavior it's a program of
understanding and of intervention that's
required alright terrific well thank you
very much thanks everyone for coming out
thank you very much over time Nick okay
and if anyone if you want to know more
about its research go to human nature
lab net and it's got tons of Nick's
papers fantastic work really worth
looking at and I'm on Twitter and it's
on Twitter thank you thanks guys thank
you so much